en este pequeño suburbio del noreste
dejar que muchas cosas han quedado
reducidas de escombros las tropas rusas
han sido expulsadas de la zona y los
residentes han empezado a regresar
dichas zonas napster y libertad ahora no
nos bombardean sólo se dispara nuestra
artillería no hay impacto sobre nosotros
por lo tanto se puede vivir en paz el
agua y la electricidad han sido
recolectadas
clutch y lujo tom harkin la segunda
ciudad de ucrania está situada apenas a
40 km de la frontera rusa y fue uno de
los primeros objetivos de los ataques
rusos en las últimas semanas las tropas
ucranianas empezaron a alejar a las
fuerzas rusas en la región hasta el
punto de que los residentes han
comenzado a regresar a la ciudad y sus
alrededores comensal turca en el noreste
de la ciudad dondequiera que mires se
puede recordar que hace sólo unos días
esto era parte de la primera línea esto
era un campo de batalla había
explosiones muy fuertes todos los días a
todas horas algunas personas al
principio querían quedarse aquí
protegiéndose en los refugios
subterráneos pero luego se dieron cuenta
de que era imposible quedarse aquí más
allá al este de la ciudad el pueblo
débil kitka los ciudadanos que viven
allí tratan de seguir adelante con sus
vidas pero quedó en su memoria los
recuerdos de la presencia rusa los
soldados rusos vivían aquí solían dormir
presuntamente durante la noche se
escondían aquí es como un búnker para
esconderse de los bombardeos dormían
aquí hay una cocina solían comer aquí lo
intentaban al menos
jarquín y sus alrededores tenían 15
millones de habitantes antes de la
invasión rusa ahora es menos de un
tercio de eso